hi i'm louie tomlinson and i'm doing a
wired auto complete interview
these are some random random google
questions
so we'll start
with this one yeah just don't peel it
off shoulder
how to pronounce louie tomlinson well
i've just done that for you well before
i was on on the x factor sorry all my
friends from back home they called me
lewis i mean my name is louie but they
called me lewis that's what i was known
as back home and then on my first
audition simon called me louie and i
went about to correct him you know what
i mean so that's that
how old is louie thomason i'm getting
older it feels like i'm getting old like
at 27 i am
how is larry tominson uh yeah i'm doing
all right thanks i'm doing all right
that's a random google one well what
does google say in response to that i'd
love to know
how can i meet louis tomlinson come to
tour come to tour and i'll meet you then
hopefully
what's up next
what is louis thomas's favorite food i
ate a lot of rubbish food probably
burgers i eat a lot of mcdonald's but in
terms of the ultimate burger it probably
has to be in and out that is a proper
burger what else we got here what is
louie thomas's zodiac sign been a lot of
talk of this while i've been doing promo
in america you guys love the zodiac
stuff capricorn i am i was told recently
about some of the characteristics of a
capricorn capricorn i think i maybe have
like two of eight
what is louis tomlinson's phone number
that is a question i won't be answering
my number's got out quite a few times i
like beyond privacy so unfortunately i'm
not gonna give you that
there's two on here
what kind of dog does louis thompson
have a great reveal at the end there i
got two dogs i got a golden doodle and i
got a labradoodle bruce and cliff
they're quite different dogs the two of
them uh bruce is like proper
well-behaved good lad proper like
almost like a pretty dog you know what i
mean i was cliff he's big he's clumsy
he's a thief because you know everyone
says dog shouldn't go anywhere near
chocolate and i think maybe two or three
easters ago
he stole a full easter egg a full easter
egg
which i was worried about but i found
out after i think as long as they don't
eat the body weight in chocolate you're
all right so he lives to fight another
day
okay
is louis thomas in british
two right get to know
oh hang on a minute well you can't see
that but it says is louis tomlinson on
tour not yet glad you asked about to go
on the road next year tickets are on
sale go have a look
there we go again
i'm getting a bit sh this now is louie
thomason a football player yeah my local
club um doncaster over is where i'm from
i was lucky enough one year i mean it
was a bit of a pr thing on their end but
also
fairly decent football player they
signed me onto the books for a year i
was in the back of the programme every
game day i got a squad number which i
got tattooed on me and 28. it was a good
time to be around
is louie thomason vegan i'm not a vegan
i'm not a vegan um i mean in england
we're doing all sorts at the moment like
vegan sausage rolls which feels like a
contradiction to me i'm not a vegan no
but respect to everyone who is
is louie thomas and left-handed no i'm
not left-handed i'm right-handed believe
it or not what more have i got to say
about my left or right-handed that's
your lot
is louie thomason nice i suppose it
depends on your ass really uh i think so
i like to think so yeah
he's a funny this one
what is louie thomas's favorite color
red i love red often trying to
incorporate red into pretty much
anything i do really creatively and also
me uh my football club donuts they play
in red so that'd be why
what is louie tomlinson just hold on
about you know it's another one of those
songs that's that's saying you know
regardless of what happens in life you
just got to try and uh be hopeful really
what is louis thompson's middle name
that'll be an obvious google answer
that's william don't use it that often i
imagine somebody fans know there's my
middle name bit trivia for you
what movies is louis tomlinson
been in i have been in the movie like
other than the one direction movie
starring that when i was really young i
did the odd bit of extra work here and
there there's one really tragic clip
online of me i think about 14 years old
out of a line but i look petrified
who is louis tomlinson who is louie
thomas's best friend
probably me ginger mate ollie goes
everywhere with me lives for me most the
time
is the songs first most of the time went
to school with him known him for like
wow like 10 years now 12 years or
something that's mad
who is louie tomlinson
x factor judge i was an ex factor judge
i've also been on the show as a
contestant i was in this bank or one
direction they were pretty big
who is louis thomas and miss you about
miss you was originally written
i was bouncing between different parties
and all the night life that la has to
offer and there was moments where i felt
like i was kind of just going along with
it without really
enjoying it so much and that's kind of
what that song was about
who did louis thompson play for i'd be
donnie rovers or if we're going far back
tickle junior sunday league sunday
league team um local area it was the
first team that i joined called tickle
juniors i think they're still going in
fact i got a mildly cheeky email from
them pretty recently uh asking for some
funding um so i'll be in touch don't
have anything more to say about her
on to where
where was louie thomason born i was born
in doncaster probably best place in the
world if you haven't been you should go
great holidays i absolutely love where i
come from great people where i'm from
and a great night out as well
where does louie tomlinson
currently live i live between la and
london and also try and get to doncaster
as much as i can quite a drastic jump
quite a different jump it just it's just
forever hot here in la you know i mean i
was just talking about that we're about
to get into november and it's red hot
and i'm just a true brit you know i mean
when it's winter i want cold
where is louie tomlinson
right now
here doing this this little piece to
camera for you
where did louis tomlinson go to school
in doncaster there was a school called
hayfield school went there for
90 of my school life then i failed my
a-levels and they didn't have me in they
wouldn't have me back in which was a bit
unfair of them so then i went to another
school for a year
and then i'm at an x factor so
where louis thompson audition i
auditioned in manchester when i did the
x factor basically long story short the
judges see
thousands of people you know across
however many days so i wanted to be at
the start of the auditions i started
queuing up at like 4 00 a.m um because i
wanted to be one of the first to be
seeing so i thought i had a better
chance then and i was right when was
louis thomason born christmas eve 1991
good times happy birthday everyone's in
a good mood
when is louie thomason going on tour
starts march next year it goes all the
way through to
june july
super excited to come on tour i feel
like i've been waiting me all solo crave
this moment so
pretty excited about that one
okay this is an interesting one when
louis tomlinson valerie i'm imagining uh
you're talking about when i started with
the band and got our first tour i did a
cover of amy winehouse valerie maybe
you're asking when i might sing that
again
the answer is i don't know
when did louie thomason perform just
hold on i performed it a few times it
came out off the top of my head i think
2017 so my first performance with that
was on the x factor you know i'd never
done a solo performance on my own and
the x factor was always a big
performance for us as a band so to come
back and do that on my own was both
exciting and nerve-wracking
last one right louis tomlinson
cute i think that says i'm not just
making the assumption i can read it
louie thomas and q again not sure how to
react to this one uh other than saying
thanks love
louie thomas and tattoos that i have
many of quite a few stupid ones i'm
trying to look at which one the latest
one was probably this horrible one that
i got done on the x factor not even
straight lines
pretty bad
louis thomas an eye color well i got
blue eyes but i'm not going to lie my
eyes do slightly change color why the
blue top look a bit bluer what they're
looking like today i don't know but
normally blue
maybe thomasin hairstyles i had that
many of them to be honest i've had like
three in rotation for last like nine
years what's pretty funny about me air
though is you know from being in a band
like one direction
i've almost forgot how to do my own air
it's pretty tragic that in it you know i
mean i'm lucky to have someone doing the
air and there's times where i go on a
night out and i'm looking at it thinking
i'll be honest i don't even know where
to start so just put a cap on
louie thomas in one direction is the
band i am in and was in whichever way
you look at it don't really know what
else to say about that good time in your
life hopefully we come back
louie thomason back to you yep that was
the name of wannabe song so i assume you
bang that into google and my song will
just pop straight up give it a listen if
you want did it with bb rex i did the
music video in doncaster where i'm from
so again that was special for me yeah
thanks for that
okay thank you very much for watching
and thank you for all of your questions
cheers